el jefe de los conservadores en escocia
y otros diputados del partido de boris
johnson se han sumado a las voces que
piden que el primer ministro renuncie
por este escándalo creciente de las
fiestas en downing street el diputado
douglas ross ha dicho que escribirá una
carta al comité 1922 de su partido
expresando que ha perdido la confianza
en su líder boris johnson si se reciben
54 cartas entonces habrá una consulta
interna sobre el liderazgo debe johnson
seguir o no como el jefe de los
conservadores o no por ahora johnson
cuenta con el apoyo de su partido pero
este está sujeto a una investigación
interna que realiza el mismo gobierno
sobre al menos 10 fiestas que se habrían
realizado en el complejo de oficinas de
dawn instruir en el centro de londres
durante el 2020 cuando el país estaba en
estricto confinamiento johnson ha
reconocido hoy en el parlamento que
rompió la ley que él mismo creó sin
embargo ha dicho que se trataba de un
evento de trabajo pero lo cierto es que
en el correo electrónico de invitación
enviado su propio secretario privado se
dejaba en evidencia que se trataba de un
evento social esto mientras el 56 por
ciento de los británicos consultados
según la última encuesta de yougov cree
que boris johnson debe renunciar